hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video as
usual guys i'm gonna go through amc and
jamie press action uh we didn't have a
good day let's be honest but we have
some good things uh that happened as
well so we're gonna analyze all of that
and see what can happen next let's get
into it
oh right guys so we're going to start
with amc daily time frame so uh we moved
down today by 3.2
i was expecting two days ago so i'm
going to remind you guys what i said
during the video i did yesterday and the
day before i was expecting a strong
buddhist reaction uh that should have
happened yesterday or today it didn't
happen well this is trading once again
um there is nothing that can ever be
guaranteed out here was wrong
but i still believe that we can see good
things and the reason behind that is
like i said once again in those videos
guys uh usually second waves uh like to
go to the top of the third wave or the
bottom of the false wave usually it is
in line with the fib ratios that are
between 38.2 and 61.8 in this situation
when i measure the first wave i'm gonna
do that again quickly with you guys for
those who haven't seen this video i
measure that
i know that we go top of the third
bottom of the force between 38.2 and
61.8 so the best uh situation for me was
uh the 61.8 retracement at 21. so i
really believed we're going to have a
buddhist reaction here yesterday we saw
bulls trying to fight strongly with some
negative that are taking place and um
they didn't manage to push the price
action higher with the nasdaq that was
dropping heavily so this was kind of
understandable and this morning once
again yes i was full of hope uh that
finally we gonna see this strong rebound
and uh we moved strongly lower guys so
let's analyze on the hourly timeframe
what happened here um we moved lower
guys quite brutally so basically 21 was
a support i told you we have a
consolidation area that is taking place
around the 21 level uh just like it did
guys um here around the 22 level just
like it did around the 26 level a little
bit below the 25th level whatever and
each time we got uh rejected bears got
the best of it and we moved lower so uh
after we broke out below this 21 level
so here you could see we fought around
this level for like
10 hours roughly and then bam strong
move down um not a big volume here the
we had a bigger a bigger volume
happening just uh the next hour when we
arrive close to this level close to the
19
support level so the good thing i see
because
once again this was not a good day once
again i was expecting we moved
strongly higher
before
it didn't happen uh we can still go
higher because we are above this 1911 at
this 19 level and what i want to show
you guys is just that here you can
clearly see that this 19 level that is
the bottom of the fourth wave as you can
see here the bottom is here not here yes
because as you can see this is still the
third wave here of this first move up
and the bottom of the fourth wave is
exactly here guys so this is at 19 let
me put it back
and
it was important
for this one two three four five dad uh
i'm expecting to go once again to the
120 level hopefully guys i know it seems
far but we can do it i think it is very
possible uh especially after the crazy
strong moves we had last week it means
that bulls are here and they're just not
well organized they're uh
bears are better organized than us um
this is a fact and they are taking
ground all right this is another fact
but the good thing is that bulls
defended very well this knight in level
so this is what i wanted to show you
guys here we can see where the first
reaction then second third false
reactions and then bam bull's got the
best of it let's zoom a little bit what
happened here where was the volume
because we can see that there was an
increase in volume
so here you can see the volume was
trading high
in the whole move down so this is not
good all right here the four five
candles here were candles were going
lower then here we had a nice reaction
first time we reached the 19 level so
this was bulls taking back control and
they took back control on no volume so
nothing very good here once again on uh
the hourly timeframe um so let's see
what's going to happen um if we re-test
tomorrow this nice in level uh let's be
honest if we break out below this next
level at some point we're going to have
a bullish action i mean this is uh how
things are working but we're gonna lose
this bullish momentum so it's very
important that we don't close below this
level we can go quickly there but a
close below 19 would
really break the bullish momentum that
has started on the on march 15th so we
want to see this level uh holding and we
want to see bulls at some point coming
back with strong volume which we not
seeing for now what uh we are looking
for right now guys um
so once again we're in the same
situation just like yesterday uh but
it's unfortunately two points lower uh
we are right we were yesterday and the
day before um consolidating around the
21 level just like we did around the 22
level right now this is what is
happening again around the 19 level so
we might see a consideration taking
place for a few more candles uh so we
might very well see the price action
coming back tomorrow to this level uh
but what we want to see guys at some
point is a breakout okay a breakout is
um an event
that
changes
the momentum so right now on the hourly
timeframe the momentum is bearish
definitely on the daily timeframe it is
bullish still guys
and we want to see this momentum
reversing on the hourly timeframe so for
the momentum to shift we need a clear
victory of balls so we need a breakout
above a level that is acting as
resistance and where bears are organized
and this level to me once again this is
subjective maybe all the traders have
another level but the clearer resistance
i see is this blue trend line let me put
it in yellow
that is here guys um and as you can see
we had multiple reactions one two three
four five six six reactions in the
recent past it is also where the 20
hours uh moving average simple moving
average is so it's a double uh
resistance and if we are able to break
out above that
resistance level so tomorrow it's
basically if we trade around 20 tomorrow
and we stay above 20 for more than one
hour uh it is very very likely that
bulls start to buy
strongly so who is going to do that
probably algorithms that can very easily
spot this resistance lines uh so we need
algorithms to be here because once again
they bring a lot of liquidity they bring
a lot of volume when you see a strong
volume uh during the day on amc or
whatever stock i can tell you that
algorithms are very much involved and of
course they're not only buy they buy and
they sell they buy understand what if
but we need at some point something to
start the move up and algorithms can
help to do that so hopefully they're
gonna be on our side tomorrow
uh let's see once again the 19 level is
very important uh what does i tell you
on the daily timeframe i was talking
about this rs i guess guys because the
rsi is what you can look at today for a
bullish or bearish uh an rsi above 50 is
bullish on rsi below 50 is bearish and
here uh we were yesterday at 49.9 and i
was telling you guys that between 45 and
55 usually booze are
trying to take back control they tried
the day before they didn't really try
today bears were in full control uh
let's be honest uh and we have an rsi at
48 so we are still in an area that is
acceptable uh what i don't like to see
is the macd usually the rsi below 50 is
going to happen together with the macd
signal turning negative so the magni
signal is what you can see here is this
bars that you have so you
when the macd signal is positive the
bars are green just like here and when
the macd signal turns negative those
bars turn red so right now we have an
rsi below 50 we have the macd signal
that turned
red for the first time
so this is showing you guys that we are
losing the daily momentum uh i would say
we are really on the limit
i'm happy to see that knight team has
hold um
has held and um i really want to see the
price action going against uh going
above this 20 level and holding there so
let's see we're gonna see what's gonna
happen uh if this happens finally with
volume this is gonna be a very big
relief for bulls we're probably gonna
gonna see quickly the press action
coming back to 22
and then 26 and then the next level
because we have here two scenarios okay
this uh down move is very strong let's
once again be very honest we lost 50 in
nine trading sessions so what can happen
is either we go higher and then lower
okay forming an abc and it means that
you know there's too bad control or we
go higher we got rejected i think that
any uh ways at 26 if we're able to go
back there um this tomorrow or next week
we're gonna have a selling reaction and
then either we keep dropping or we
rebound so here um i'm gonna keep buying
whatever happens because i'm waiting at
least for that um
on the normal stock i would of course
take profit here we're talking here
about amc guys buy and hold so i'm not
gonna sell what i bought once again i
only buy
what i can lose uh i bought a lot of
options i'm gonna keep buying some um
and and and i'm gonna hope that you know
booze just get the best of it uh but
once again this strong move down is
gonna
be
now um is gonna create some attacks from
bears all right if we had moved
higher before like two days ago uh bears
here would have been scared
around 26. now we're gonna have probably
back holders exiting some of their long
positions we're gonna have some bears
attacking so 26 is going to be another
major resistance then we're going to
have to do 233 but if we come back to 32
to the three it's gonna be much easier
so um this is the situation guys once
again we are in a move that is strongly
uh moving lower um
we can move lower let's be honest the
next support is at 16. i don't want to
talk about that because
i don't want to see the price action
trading below 19 especially closing
there because once again it would break
the bullish momentum that we have
created
in the past two three weeks guys so um
this is my view i told you everything um
once again i don't know what's gonna
happen but
uh i think that a strong bullish
reaction from here would make sense and
would validate the fact that we're still
developing in a massive one two three
four five that can go at crazy levels so
let's find out let's see what's going to
happen jme guys so once again jme was um
developing in a much stronger way than
amc we can see that gme didn't even
touch the 50 feet ratio of the first
move up uh today jamie lost four percent
amc three percent i'm going to talk
about the spread but we are roughly at
21 22
a discount for amc
um
we have as you can see here the macd is
still very not very positive but still
the macd positive the rsi at 55. so this
is showing you guys that the bullish
momentum on gme is still very strong and
that we can have a few more
red days before bulls start to lose
confidence for now on gme bulls are very
confident bears are not attacking that
much they are attacking amc right now
and at some point i think they're gonna
stop attacking game cmc is gonna you
know uh catch up on gme and those two
are gonna finally move together and do
the very strong moves we're expecting
them to do for a very long time i really
believe this will happen but let's be
very honest i don't know if it's gonna
happen this is what i'm personally
playing and once again i'm gonna keep
buying uh every today so today i didn't
buy i'm gonna buy tomorrow um for those
who want to follow what i'm doing guys
just join the discord the link is in the
description of this video um i'm also
gonna give you some updates guys on
triple q so yesterday we bought at 350
51
uh
351.5 let's be precise uh so i'm quite
happy to see what happened today so
usually after a gap down you don't have
a strong rebound right this is not what
is happening usually after a gap down
like we had uh yesterday
you have you know a consolidation around
this area so today we are consolidating
just above the 350 level we have a green
candle uh we ended up the day positive
uh 24 beeps so this is good to me uh i'm
talking about 3.3 guys because once
again my view and you can check the
video i did three or four days ago uh
when we were here i told you i was
bearish and i told you that i'm afraid
we're gonna come here i was having a
short position that i uh closed with
profits um and right now i'm expecting
the price action to go higher i'm not
building a long position yet because
this signal is not strong enough to me
um i'm of course long on stocks but i
don't make a long position for now on
triple two i'm still expecting the price
action to rebound if we have this
rebound uh it's gonna be much harder for
bears to keep attacking amc so they'll
probably you know give us some relief
and then boos are gonna be back to are
gonna be able to take back control so
this is the scenario that uh i i'm
having for the past uh three four days
uh even two weeks um i was starting to
tell you guys that amc will do a second
wave once again i was not expecting such
a deep second wave
but we have this deep second wave and i
still believe a third wave can happen as
long as we stay above 19. very quickly
if we go below 19 and come back to 16
we're gonna have the strong bullish
reaction at some point but it's gonna be
much tougher to keep pushing higher
because uh the bullish momentum would
have been broken and bears would be
stronger more confident and bulls would
be like all right should i just close my
position because i'm scared to lose
money so we don't want that to happen we
want booze to be confident we want best
to be scared
right now bears are becoming more
confident so let's see guys i'm really
hoping that tomorrow at least for the
end of the week we're gonna have a
strong distraction uh everything is uh
very uh possible it is still looking
good to me in terms of levels because we
are we are only at the bottom of the
fourth wave which is a typical
retracement level for a second wave so
let's see guys i'm gonna keep updating
you whatever happens i'm gonna be here
and we're gonna find out together if
we're able to go to this to this crazy
level guys 134 mc
860 for gme so that's it for today i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
going to be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i'll see you guys